[Music]
uh very good evening the taliban are
rapidly advancing towards the afghan
capital cup on august the 12th while i
presented sky news tonight in the
comfort of a secure television studio
one of our news teams had arrived on the
ground in afghanistan faced with a very
different environment it's fierce
fighting in the country's second city of
kandahar
thousands of people have fled the
fighting and sought sanctuary in the
capital more than 12 000 displaced
people where they can find a space they
huddle in family groups
every day more and more skies chief
correspondent stuart ramsey along with
his producer and camera operator began
reporting on the developing situation as
far as turning into a major humanitarian
crisis the numbers of displaced people
grow by the day even the hour
in the days that followed they captured
the harrowing images many of us have
seen on our screens
and recorded the desperate stories of
those trying to flee as the taliban took
control
but they couldn't show us everything
on a special edition of the sky news
daily podcast with me dermot monahan
stuart and his team take us behind the
camera to reflect on a week in kabul
[Music]
right do a clap and then we can start
ready
i'm stuart ramsey um i'm the reporter
we're outside in the compound where the
british
relief effort is underway it's quite
noisy there's always generators there's
always planes taking off occasionally
you'll hear shooting that's people
trying to control crowd i'm dominique uh
dominique van gerden i'm stuart's
producer and
i made a cough
and i do more than make coffee dominique
makes sure we don't get ourselves into
trouble and basically does all the hard
stuff
and i'm toby nash i shoot edit and
misplace things for sky news
[Music]
we're all here in kabul um we've been
here now for how long feels like months
we started before
the taliban took the city
and then we arrived and i think we did
um
immediately came off the plane and did a
camp for internally displaced people
that seems like such a long time i don't
know actually that feels like a
different time
[Laughter]
we came into kabul and we had
heard about hundreds maybe thousands of
refugees in the in the camp
arrived from maza isharif a day ago
joining 1800 families in this park went
and filmed that that was one of the
first things we filmed
and it was a park toby it was in a park
yeah
it was quite tense i think because there
was still fear that there were
armed groups that maybe within these
refugee groups and everything we were
definitely very sort of on edge when we
went in weren't we and a lot of people
they were there were some people they're
very definitely not pleased to see us i
remember it was over quite quickly
we had to leave in something of a hurry
it's sort of one of those ones where it
was like the local population was sort
of beginning to move towards
all the trouble being being the cause by
outsiders and we were sort of the
outside
that's right
and even before the taliban came to
kabul um
the streets were tense you know we had
to be very mindful about how we were
filming
farida kurasani's husband and brother
both police officers were killed by the
taliban in kunduz
they were attacked in their police
station
she escaped to kabul with her two
children
she has nothing now
she feels failed by everyone
very very short amount of times outside
the vehicles uh just sort of in and out
and the military and the police were
incredibly
on edge yeah everyone's jumping because
turn around getting nearer and nearer by
a
minute
literally
yeah it turns out they may have already
been here
the real impression you get here is that
people feel that carnival is being
surrounded or it's certainly going to be
in the coming weeks
so we spent a few days filming around
kabul and um i don't think any of us
expected it to fall on the sunday
that took us by surprise we'd heard the
previous night they were around seven
miles from kabul and they there was the
breakout from the prison on the edge
that's right but given it's such a big
city and kandahar was it took a while to
fall and it's the second largest city
and we thought even if they were at the
so-called gates of kabul that it would
take a good few days and i think we all
went to bed thinking that we didn't go
to bed thinking the next day it would
fall i think we were quite tense that
night i remember thinking they are only
seven to ten miles away or whatever i
didn't sleep well well we all got calls
oh the foreign office phoned us in the
middle of the night yeah saying where
are you and uh we need to put your names
down and we need to identify where you
are and eventually we'll have to call
you to go
i would know i was told there was i i
was offered a flight that afternoon so
they called me at three in the morning
on sunday and said there's a flight at
four
no much quicker so then so we get to
sunday yeah so sunday was but it started
off very normally right we had the you
know your live to do that morning and
toby and i um
went up to the roof to uh well first of
all we've had a few false alarms on sort
of should we move from our hotel or not
that morning because the taliban were
apparently about two and a half miles by
morning so we it was kind of a mad rush
of do we pack do we go do we stay do we
go
i wanted
incredibly within all of this we are
able to get coffee
you'd done a call into sky just to say
you know the new info coming in and toby
and i ran up to the roof we had a
position at the hotel we were staying at
that
it's very high position it's at least
four stories up and it overlooks the
street
it's near the presidential palace where
we set up to do it live but when toby
and i got on the roof it was just sort
of there were gunshots and people
running and we weren't really sure
police were on the move at speeds they
were something
i still don't think we ever really
figured out what was going on there did
we we think actually it was well we
don't know the taliban had already made
i doubt god knows it might have just
been a diversion
it might have been the president leaving
spooked cops could really i don't know
but it spoke to everybody and
people were running about and so i i
called stuart i said you better get up
to the roof and he came running up and
um
yeah we went live a lot of shouting uh
coming down the road behind me in fact
it is a
i think it's a procession of uh
of the taliban uh yes it is there's the
white flag
and at that point when we were live all
the all the choppers were you know
flying overhead and
it suddenly went from feeling like quite
a tent city to a city
i don't want to say under attack it
makes it sound a bit extreme because it
wasn't actually a very but it made it
seem like the the helicopters hovering
around the city we saw more air
than we'd seen in the days before the
americans started evacuating the embassy
that's what prompted the panic because
you had seemingly every chopper they had
in country just ferrying people from the
ground to the embassy all day
the saigon moment that joe biden said he
didn't want yeah and that photo now
exists you know um and that i think was
what prompted the panic the taliban
hadn't i don't think entered certainly
not the center of town at that point but
they might as well have done i think
program quickly morphed into not a story
about afghanistan but open-ended and so
that means we're pretty much going to be
live
apart from the odd break the whole time
so we were live and then um you know i
was kind of standing to the side
listening to stuart live and there they
are right here sort of heard him saying
they keep going past this hotel i mean i
was as confused as the viewer trust me
that's right i was on i was on a box
which is in the sort of center of the
roof
a variety of reasons but it's the shot
but i could see down into the street but
nobody could see anything except me but
i heard this charting and i remember
turning around
and there it was the white flag of the
load of talibs and you couldn't capture
it because of the way that i'm 10 meters
back i'm using a special lens which
means that even if i could have picked
the camera from run to the edge i
wouldn't have been able to film them or
if i would i would have filmed a very
very close shot of like half of one of
their bodies yeah so i i ran over but i
think i got the tail end on an iphone
shot so but i think that moment anyway
the way you described it to do it the
way you described it to the viewer and
the way you described what you were
seeing it was as good as seeing it
yeah well
but it was that was like oh right okay
well we know they're here
are they going to come in the storm
as it turns out they didn't though but
we made the decision to move anyway
there was a variety of security issues
one of the worst security issues being
caused by the head of security at the
hotel but he decided to leg it
and uh it made sense to come to a new
location which is actually a functioning
hotel and our view was that we would get
here and move in and out this place
being closer to the airport which was
our thinking which was not not being
blocked between where we were in the
airport yeah i'd rather have the taliban
between me and my story than me and my
root out in a situation like this was
like was my position on it so yeah
exactly so we moved here and then it's
sort of in the in the following days
kind of became something of an
accidental embed
because the british military moved in as
well well i remember in the morning i
saw you in the morning and you were
furious
furious
stuart we made the wrong decision i
always said it from the beginning we
shouldn't be here we're locked in the
story's out sunlight
you definitely did that i did but but
but that was with good reason it's
because the military would not open the
gates for us we weren't allowed to go
outside to film anything we were stuck
inside here and we had no control
over our movements i remember talking to
some of the other journalists who had
come as well and eventually saying
this is rubbish
but we are actually where the story is
because it is all about the airport
because the takeover have been so quick
and seamlessly useful that's true but
but the story wasn't here yet the story
was about the taliban being in town at
that point and we were and we were
frustrated that we couldn't and our
colleagues were out there and we were
frustrated that we couldn't be there i'm
sure they were really charming yes i'm
sure they were
but then i i think i woke up on the
wednesday morning and
i was
just wide awake and i thought to myself
wow
we're actually being completely
ridiculous
the story is literally at our front gate
why are we trying to get out of here
so in the day we wandered over to the
soldiers and we didn't ask them if we
can go out and film we just said we're
going out to film and
they sort of just let us out and
they began a remarkable few days of
coverage of what was going on
just outside the airport the streets are
really empty i mean we were here uh uh
only
a day or so ago and in the hours from
this morning we could see it was
absolutely
shock about with people
now uh
it's uh it's it's pretty quiet
pretty empty we kept changing right
every day
you know
because in reality we've only moved a
few hundred meters for the last week now
if i'm trying to film stuff you always
want to make sure that it looks new and
interesting for the viewer and every day
i step out at that gate and it's the
scene has changed completely it's like a
new film set's been built waheed was a
british army translator in helmand
now he and his family are going to the
uk it's been agreed this is a very
a very happy day in my life and you
captured some pretty remarkable moments
toby many of which ended up on the front
pages of national newspapers well that's
a weird feeling actually that's never
happened before particularly the
soldiers carrying babies yeah i mean
that when you think about it it's
newspaper material isn't it in fact it's
probably better as a photo than it was
as the video as good as video but the
single image that whenever all over all
the papers
and this is a soldier carrying a baby
that's been pushed through the fence
with her mother this wasn't the day that
went completely crazy was it the day
before i think this is all relative
it's crazy every day
thousands of africans who are coming who
have no right to come here but they're
coming anyway and they they can't just
leave them to get crushed in and the
heat is terrible and there's lots of
children so the first day we arrived
right we we went out and there was
soldiers and people right in their faces
next day there was barbed wire and even
more people in their faces yeah the next
day there were two broken down cars that
had been stuck in the middle of the road
covered in barbed wire yeah the next day
if you remember that the day after the
cars with the barbed wire the next day
we went out and that entire barricade
had been destroyed in the night the cars
had been pushed to one side and the
soldiers were holding the line and the
day after that they put overnight they
put the shipping containers in which is
the thing that held
we got quite comfortable though in our
position with the soldiers outside and
until the day we stepped out and there
weren't any soldiers outside and they
weren't there
that was a moment yeah
literally walk up can you go out and i
just said you you want to go out no i
think you said like yeah don't go too
far at no point did he say there are no
soldiers out there immediately outside
this gate is the taliban
um so when the gate opens and they're
there none of us are ready for it the
first person we see has got a beard and
a machine gun
yeah what's incredible
just one step away
there's a taliban right next to the
british
forces who were trying you said i didn't
expect this now everyone wave
gave them a wave and they sort of gave a
nod and we filmed
but it's been a remarkable few days
filming and
i think stu you didn't expect the
stories to be so
go so big i guess
it's just horrendous taliban hitting
people the saturday was one of the worst
things i've ever seen ever anywhere i've
done loads of awful things wars
disasters refugee crises but i've never
seen anything like this no 10 000 people
trying to get through a gap
and people died as a result then there
was nothing anyone can do and that's
when it stopped being
a system by which they're trying to work
out who kind of can't come to the to a
processing system for who can or can't
come through but soldiers are actually
saving lives and literally it was a
rescue operation it had nothing to do
with anything anymore no no they weren't
processing anyone that did they just had
to hold the line and stop people dying
sometimes we can manage to turn the crew
down
the soldiers out here have been i have
to say amazing
and these are para's
shocked roots
really hard
and the compassion and sort of care
they've shown to the afghans has been
incredible
and they've been incredibly polite and
helpful with us as well that day
was very different and i wouldn't hold
it against them for a second but
they were operating to the limits of
their capacity just to keep a lid on
that situation and save as many lives as
possible and i got shouted out and told
in no uncertain terms to get out the way
and i have no grudges with that at all
because they were doing an incredible
job and the medics were just literally
jumping from one casualty to another
casual to you another casualty it never
stopped no
i mean and boiling hot yeah and i think
you know i think the one thing to
remember is that a lot of that we
couldn't even show
we couldn't even show on tv
fatima is terrified
her husband joined the taliban and took
to beating her
she and her four-year-old daughter have
nothing but a u.n letter identifying
them as victims
afghanistan is told about thought about
his twitter is my husband
my husband is a
tourist
[Music]
this doctor from herratu is with her
sister and her mother have absolutely no
rights to get through the gates
they fled the taliban and are now stuck
they have hope
but it seems hopeless we don't have any
brother we don't have father you know
that
living in here is very difficult for us
we were living in gerard and we escaped
from herald and came to kabul city to
save our life because i filmed things
that will never ever be seen by anyone
you know we're making a documentary out
of this and i transferred all the
russians back to the uk
and i had to warn the editor i said on
that day if you're advisory you need to
be very careful
like no one should be watching that who
doesn't have to because there's stuff on
there that is absolutely horrific yeah
traumatic i had to shoot it i'm not
being gruesome but you had
if you're shooting a body you have to
i'm waiting for them to cover the body
so we have an image that we can show
that can convey to people that people
are dying
but they haven't covered the bodies and
they're carrying the bodies and
it's
these these are young young women i mean
well you picture you shut up the picture
you can't show but you've shot the
picture you can't show so how is that
how that affects you it's weird i when
you're actually working and you're
shooting
your mind is full of a lot of
technical things that you have to
consider the composition the technical
the exposure all these things focus so
actually it always acts as a kind of
distraction
and in a way it's
harder when you're looking back at it
and you're editing with it because then
you're just watching it and years ago
during the yazidi
crisis the sinjar mountain during the
when isis took northern iraq
i flew onto sinjar mountain in a
helicopter and we picked a load of
people and we came back and then the
next day we went back to the air base to
film and the same helicopter took off to
pick people up
and it crashed taking off the mountain
it killed both the pilots lots of kid
people on the helicopter and the iraqi
guys
said to me when they sent their only
other servers were helicopters to pick
up the casualties can you not film this
out of respect and i said fine
and that was the first time i've ever
actually just watched a horrible thing
happen i'm always behind a bank of
technical questions which is a defense
from this stuff and when you guys are
just watching things without any filter
it's i think it's probably much harder
for you
the camera is a sort of barrier
i think what i found most overwhelming
is just the volume of people who want
help
who write to you and call and say please
help me please help my family please
help me
get through the barriers please help my
case
we tried as a team we've tried to help
as many people as we can especially you
know people
whose documentation is absolutely spot
on british citizens etc we've done our
best to help
but uh there's no you can never do
you can never do enough and 90 of the
people who write to you because you've
had these discussions with the foreign
office people here
and they send you all their documents
you look at them and you know they've
got no chance and now you're the person
who has to tell them no
it's heartbreaking i don't you know i've
never had this before that's probably
i've found that the hardest thing
is
not being able to help but you do help
no but you can't help everyone no you
kind of at the point when you know what
you're leaving someone to and there's
nothing you can do to help them and
you're communicating with them
it's well in the other words but is this
the volume of children
i tell what was amazing it was one of
the stories of the
military telling me that they would uh
we saw it of course but
they call it simbering
it doesn't matter where you look it's
the same desperation american soldiers
pulling children whole families from the
pens they're being kept behind for
processing
they would see these kids little between
five and ten years old who have just
sort of wandered through the crowd
and uh somehow got themselves on the
wrong side of the barricade split from
their parents
soldiers would uh pick them up and
simber them up in the air and hold them
up is that what they call it i didn't
know they called it simmering yeah and
uh and they said hold him up and then
in the crowd you'd they'd see a wave of
someone and then their family
and then they would lower the kids down
and they'd be passed over their heads
that's how they're doing it i wonder i
mean you see kids separated everywhere
yeah
missing children i mean because families
are split all the time yeah there are
plenty of people who don't know
[Music]
they they don't know they don't have any
idea who these kids are attached to and
i don't know how they're gonna do it
[Music]
okay you're going to go grab them
okay okay
so are you uh you told him to go all the
way around to the next one okay fine
he'll get here in the end
so interestingly this is us literally
helping someone get in at the moment
do any spores
[Music]
if you take it just from the soldiers
themselves they've never seen anything
like it never been involved in anything
like it multiple tour
died in the world paratroopers who
say that they are in tears their men are
in tears
they're exhausted but i i've i've never
been involved in a story like this
because i've tried
that you know you it is a relief
operation a humanitarian relief
operation
in a war zone
with politicians thousands of miles away
saying things are all going jolly well
when actually they're going really jolly
badly
i struggled to contain my anger about
that you may have noticed
no but that is why eyewitness journalism
is so important and being here is so
important and even though it's an
extremely challenging assignment and
when it's all said and done i'm sure
we'll all talk about it and we'll kind
of reflect on it but um
for now it's just getting the story out
so that the reality of it is not sort of
hidden well i mean it was a funny thing
we called it the accidental embed yeah
you know we were in a hotel and it
became a military base
overnight
and basically with the volume of people
outside and the taliban everywhere
getting here came almost impossible so
we were in and could see what was going
on and everyone on the outside couldn't
get in but they could see what we were
filing it was a sort of an amazing story
to be in but
both fortunate and unfortunate at the
same time and none of it
did we know exactly how it was going to
go no we knew the airport was the right
story to do
but our location was
thrust upon us as opposed to
thought out in a strategic way
dominique's right you know there was a
moment when all our colleagues are
running around
downtown kabul on the first day we got
here we were stuck inside here
that we maybe all wondered if we'd done
the wrong thing yeah it's always guess
work on stories you never really know
how it's going to go but this one
clearly is going down in history the
fall of kabul and what happened and the
withdrawal of all the forces i mean it's
a huge moment in history i started
coming here 2001 and here we are
20 years later and
most of my adult life might the best
part of my adult life has been covering
afghanistan in one form or another
and it started with a
a huge explosion a terror attack and
here it is ends with
a superpower and it's supporting armies
leaving with the taliban back in charge
it's completely bizarre you know this
you know you've both been here but
if you spend time here in during the war
being face to face like less than a
meter away from the taliban is
mind-bending
because you often wouldn't even really
see them if you're in somewhere like
helmand you'd hear them you'd see the
effect of them but they're in a
concealed position
firing they learned very quickly not to
show themselves in hellmann because
there were apaches and things that would
take them out and they're right in front
of you oh i've never been that close to
them it's absolutely astounding
in reality the situation is the military
had to cooperate with them otherwise the
situation
there would be no evacuation and i think
for the i think for the guys in the
parish that's all the soldiers here
that's just the strangest thing
i think it's the strangest thing for all
of us what a
tragic story that's going to take some
thinking
[Music]
my thanks to stuart dominique and toby
there reflecting on their deployment to
kabul for this special edition of the
sky news daily podcast you can keep
across what's happening in afghanistan
and all the political fallout on sky
news and across our digital channels as
well
this episode was produced by annie joyce
along with rob fellowes and simon
windsor
[Music]
you